bonjour alexandre langlois merci à
d'être avec nous sur rt france
étrangement je pense pas que cette étude
étonne le racisme dans la police n'est
pas vraiment la première fois qu'on n'en
parle non malheureusement ce n'était pas
la première fois qu'on en parlait bon
bah du coup il n'y a pas grand chose qui
est fait vous n'avez déjà l'air et déjà
rien que pour les conditions de travail
de nos collègues des collègues dans
l'institution sont victimes de d'autres
collègues de raciste effectivement
coincé en plus vers l'extérieur il ya
encore des choses à travailler également
donc ce n'est pas étonnant par contre ce
qui est aussi dramatique c'est que c'est
pris deux ans pour que cette affaire
puisse aboutir
et ça c'est réellement dramatique alors
il ya des fellahs et relate et non pas
par une victime mais par un policier à
un lanceur d'alerté finalement est-ce
que ça change pas un peu tout ça change
ça change si ça change a effectivement
les choses que ce que j'ai toujours la
parole d'un policier qui est normalement
je dois faire respecter la loi donc
lille et dans le cadre de son travail
par contre ce qui est assez amusant
l'envoi les images d'unité sgp c'est
qu'on ôte aux délégués noah manoir avait
également dénoncé des propos racistes au
cra de will travail est donc le centre
de rétention administrative
c'est lui qui a été sanctionné ce
syndicales à l'époque avaient voté sa
sanction donc en fait il ya l'impression
que certains syndicats essayent de se
racheter une virginité aujourd'hui alors
que quand l'on essayé de faire le
travail depuis des années il y avait
personne pour nous soutenir
vous admettez qu'il ya parfois du
racisme dans la police votre collègue
dont vous venez de parler monsieur noir
est déjà venu ici l'a fait également
il ya aussi beaucoup de policiers qui ne
veulent pas l'admettre ou peut-être
qu'ils n'ont pas vus est ce que pour
éviter de généraliser certains
comportements et de pointer du doigt
toute une profession
est ce que certains policiers refuse
justement de parler de racisme
alors non la profession en fait déjà il
ya les possibles refuse pas spécialement
de paris de racistes ceux qui le font
ils le font sciemment après il ya aussi
une sur médiatisation de certains
événements par exemple streetpress avait
révélé deux groupes facebook en disant
il ya neuf mille policiers qui tiennent
des propos racistes non y avait neuf
mille inscrits sur ces groupes facebook
par exemple et une cinquantaine à chaque
fois qu'ils tenaient des propos racistes
donc il faut garder les toutes
proportions gardées et après les
policiers n'ont parlant de forcément
envie de parler parce que quand il parle
ou qu'ils essaient de faire les choses
ils ont leur hiérarchie sur l'endos ils
sont passés en conseil discipline il
souleva noter c'est ce qui arrive
également on a pu voir des notes de
commissaires qui gère le
notre collègue qui a fait les
dénonciations au tribunal effectivement
il ya eu des comportements de manque de
loyauté et c'est donc on nous oppose le
manque de loyauté pour cacher tous les
dysfonctionnements internes et les
policiers n'ont pas forcément les moyens
les l'envi de perdre leur dynamisme leur
tranquillité leur vie de famille passé
une machine qui est là pour nous broyer
alors en trois ans l'ensemble des ces
faits ont fait l'objet de plusieurs
rapports il me semble que l'igpn a été
saisie pourquoi on sait pas alerté
plutôt pourquoi ya pas une sanction à la
faudrait poser la question aux pouvoirs
publics parce que bon c'est toujours
pareil et toute une chaîne hiérarchique
une inertie l'igpn ou demandent sa
dissolution pour qu elles sont
remplacées par un contrôle indépendant
parce que évidemment quand des
commissaires son copain entre eux ou
alors on remet en cause des gens très
importants l'igpn n'est pas du tout
impartial dans ses enquêtes
là évidemment c'est le ça peut être le
cas également bien qu'ils ont l'air
d'avoir fait le travail nécessaire sur
ce dossier c'est tout à leur honneur
parce que j'ai pas une effectivement en
tant qu'institution pose des problèmes
de suspicion c'est pas pour autant que
les fonctionnaires qui sont à
l'intérieur et qui font des enquêtes ne
font pas consciencieusement essaye de
faire au mieux dans le cadre légal qu'on
leur laisse donc ça prend du temps
effectivement bas ce qui serait
intéressant c'est que les lanceurs
d'ailleurs soient protégés c'est que nos
politiques surtout se saisisse du sujet
directement voilà tant qu'il n'y aura
pas de contrôle politique et citoyen ça
ne marchera pas elle a étouffé la faire
étouffer la faire je ne sais pas parce
qu'elle finit par sortir par contre on a
eu il ya eu des pressions sur notre
collègue comme à chaque fois dans la
police nationale
quelqu'un dénonce des dysfonctionnements
et des riffs plutôt que de les régler on
veut les camoufler carabas tout le monde
joue sa carrière sur le pas de vagues et
c'est assez malheureux donc camoufler
peut-être pas car la sphère finit par
sortir tous les cas ralentir la sortie
de la terre sur ben monsieur là on voit
alexandre langlois merci d'avoir été
avec mon genre apple vous êtes
secrétaire général du syndicat de police
jugée merci